revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 rosa pérez más de un me
acompaña la mañana de este martes en el
estudio rosa hoy es el día precisamente
en la libertad de prensa centrado en la
era digital donde nosotros nos estamos
en este momento en estos tiempos ahora
que hemos hablado otra vez muchos
pedazos del programa informático de
espionaje a manos de distintos estados
en el medio español el mundo soñar
entonces rosa algunas de las
personalidades internacionales que han
sido atacadas con esta tecnología y
encontramos a ciertos periodistas un
texto de carlos fresneda además también
con este catalán gates y también que
ayer se supo que pegasus es pleno e hizo
un espionaje digamos al presidente el
gobierno español y a la ministra no
buenos días raúl exactamente no tal y
como nos dice este texto en la software
pegasus es considerado el más penetrante
en términos de ciberespionaje y se
considera que alrededor de 50 mil
personas en el mundo han sido hackeadas
con este programa informático de
tecnología israelí pero vamos a
centrarnos en las personalidades del
periodismo y la comunicación que figuran
en esta lista y que fueron espiadas
con esta herramienta es una lista que
encabeza en términos de personalidades
de la comunicación el mexicano cecilio
pineda abierto que fue asesinado
tiroteado después de participar en un
acto público en el que señaló posibles
vínculos entre las autoridades locales
mexicanos y pues el crimen organizado y
se considera que esta tecnología podría
haber ayudado a localizarlo en el
momento después de su asesinato por otro
lado también en arabia saudi encontramos
pues el caso de jamalca sour y
particularmente en la embajada de arabia
saudí en a turquía y se considera pues
que esta herramienta tecnológica sirvió
para espiar a su mujer y también para
monitorear las investigaciones turcas
sobre el asesinato e incluso para
pinchar las conversaciones entre juez y
fiscal por otro lado también encontramos
que en el reino unido- la directora del
financial times rule a calaf también fue
espiada por precisamente autoridades de
arabia saudí en 2018 antes de que
ocupara el cargo y era directora adjunta
en ese momento en marruecos omar radio y
también un caso paradigmático que human
rigth watch considera que las
autoridades marroquíes hacen un abuso
del sistema de justicia para silenciar
voces críticas en azerbaiyán también
cadilla ismailova que dijo temer no
solamente por su vida sino también por
la de sus fuentes no y bueno también
encontramos distintos casos en hungría
india y pues en otros países
lamentablemente alrededor del mundo rosa
el orden mundial precisamente explica
por qué es hoy que se celebre y se
conmemora el día de la libertad de
prensa
exactamente porque como bien decías en
la introducción este 3 de mayo coincide
con el día en que se firmó la
declaración de wind hope también una
iniciativa de la unesco
conjuntamente con representantes de
distintos medios de comunicación
africanos para promover la libertad de
prensa en el continente y precisamente
raúl también en este día la unesco da un
premio que se llama premio unesco en
libertad de prensa guillermo
en relación también al periodista
colombiano que fue asesinado en
1986 frente a la redacción del
espectador donde trabajaba aquí en
bogotá y precisamente este año este
premio este reconocimiento ha ido para
la asociación de periodistas de belarús
que precisamente la justicia de belarús
quiso disolver en 2021 el agosto pasado
que destacamos entonces el informe sobre
la libertad de prensa 2022 realizado por
la organización reporteros sin fronteras
rosa pues hay distintos puntos por un
lado señala la polarización mediática y
política alrededor del mundo los efectos
desastrosos del caos informativo en un
espacio digital globalizado y sin
regular que favorece las informaciones
falsas y la propaganda crítica tanto el
desarrollo de medios de comunicación
dice opi nativos como foxnews
particularmente como medios de
comunicación en más en manos dice de
regímenes despóticos y señala a raúl
unos comentarios que nosotros aquí
destacamos en su momento también de
margarita simonián directora jefe de rt
cuando él dijo que ninguna gran nación
podía
existir sin control de la información y
precisamente este informe considera
paradigmático el uso de la propaganda en
el contexto de la invasión rusa de
ucrania y pues a la cola de este ránking
mundial encontramos corea del norte pero
también eritrea irán o china o rusia en
el puesto 155 de 180 territorios pues
digamos analizados por reporteros sin
fronteras y si te parece veamos en el
mapa un poco la situación vemos que
noruega dinamarca y suecia encabezan la
lista con buena nota pero nos fijamos en
el continente americano donde reporteros
sin fuente sin fronteras considera que
venezuela nicaragua honduras y cuba
presentan una situación para la libertad
de prensa pues muy grave y vamos a eeuu
donde pues se considera ellos mismos se
consideran a menudo un poco el paradigma
no de la libertad de expresión y la
libertad de prensa y vemos que no está
precisamente en verde y es que esta
organización señala como el monopolio el
hecho de la concentración mediática en
manos de unas pocas corporaciones puedes
degrada la pluralidad y la libertad de
prensa y en las noticias destacadas en
relación con este país señala la propia
campaña de reporteros sin fronteras para
que reino unido no extradite
precisamente a julian assange a eeuu
rosa gracias por toda la información hoy
el día de la libertad de prensa donde
celebramos y donde mejor dicho peleamos
por nuestros derechos de ejercer una
prensa libre y justa a rózsa muchísimas
gracias por toda la información pasamos
a saludar a nuestro primer invitado el
día